it's
okay hi everyone we are continuing a
design review of the foreign function
interface functionality for the compiler
Force language
all right where have we got to last time
right so
um I mean last time was a little
disorganized I mean we had sort of
several different things we were talking
about and and so on so there have been a
few things from last time that I've I've
implemented and then there's sort of a
list of sort of design decisions to talk
about after that so first just quickly
so the first thing is I I made sort of
this uh promoted this sort of load
external Library mechanism to be sort of
a bit more prominent so it's a bit
cleaner now and it's actually exported
and then now there's this foreign
instead of create and call for and
function there's just foreign function
which takes you know the library the
name and the type and produces a foreign
function object which you can you know
call with that's super cool
uh okay hold on hold on let me ask a
question here the load external Library
Thing what other isn't there a load what
other functions are there with names
similar to that
well the most similar is Library load in
fact actually there's a there's a
section below or one of the design
decisions below I think the first one
has to do with this so so I mean
basically
um
right so so basically the the
observation is this flow is almost
identical to library load and Library
function load like Library function load
has basically the same
um
the same signature except that it takes
its tight signature a bit differently
um and of course it has a much more
restricted set of types it can take and
the uh and the library is specified with
a string so basically everywhere in the
system in sort of the library you know
find library library load Library unload
etc those all work by referring to
libraries by strings that represent
their paths
um
and uh right and secretly on the inside
it has sort of a library pointer
um but right so one option would be to
try I mean this requires a little bit of
a small amount of Kernel stuff
um but but one option would be to try
and connect this to that mechanism so
that you just put a string here just
like you would for Library function load
and uh and it was sort of tie in with
that mechanism
right I mean why not let us interoperate
between strings and the um on these
objects if it can I mean tough luck
right but I think that would be as an
alternative to this right
you were interested Christopher I think
this makes sense in the idea of having
some symbolic object like that external
Library form I think we discussed the
idea of having a two argument form of
Library load where the second argument
would specify yeah exactly something
like give me back an external Library
handle instead of just a file path so
it'd be a backwards compatible way of
adding this functionality
to the most similar existing system
function
um right and then I guess if we
supported this then we would also
support well so two things so the first
thing is if we supported this we'd also
want to be able to take this Library
object or whatever it would be called
we'd want to be able to accept that
inside of functions like Library
function load
and then we'd also want to be able to
uh right and then this would presumably
take both a path like Library function
node does or this Library object
um yeah and I assume the library object
always has a path as it's
I mean maybe I don't know you could
imagine for example in cases where like
the compiler has jitted something that's
not in a file I don't even know if that
makes sense to represent with this
mechanism but I would imagine for the
most part these external Library objects
are one-to-one compatible with a path
right like virtually every library is a
path on your computer somewhere
so the path is just a shorthand for the
office
um well kind of so the only case that
doesn't exist although I'm not sure how
safe this case is is there there's
there's
um
uh there's not okay there's basically a
thing called like the the rtld default
or something like that which is
basically the library handle that you
use when you just want to load it like
from The Ether like from the process and
you don't know you don't have a library
handle basically I mean whether it's a
byte array and the byte array is going
to run against the RTL no where the
library is already LinkedIn
kernel
right it's where the library's been
linked into the kernel and when it was
when the library was linked in it was
linked in with this kind of global
option which is the one that we use for
Library load by the way you know which
just sort of spews the symbols into the
process I see so that you can access
pieces of the library that were not
hooked up to the way that it was hooked
up exactly and there might not it might
not be obvious what the library is
called you know if it's like the C
runtime library or something it's
exactly right well where are we going to
define those are we going to have
documentation for those somewhere or
what are we going to do well I mean I
think it already like for example if I
do this I think this will work
someone told me this is it just takes a
double right not a float I think
so if I
yeah yeah
what is going on there so this is
loading there's a function called cosine
in the C standard Library every process
you know has this linked into it
so I'm just opening this I'm just
getting a function point there for the
function called cosine and calling it
but how does it know what the base
library is I mean how does it know this
is loading it so if you don't specify a
base Library so in the one below I gave
it an external Library object and this
one I didn't if you don't it uses this
again it uses this thing where it
basically loads from the process from
the sort of global namespace so is there
something else like openssl is that
loaded into the global namespace yeah it
is usually I'm not sure it's not a good
idea to rely on it but I have some
examples that do stuff like that right
and I imagine math link functions as
well are things that are just built into
the kernels default
how do you do a discovery of what's
built in
of what's available
I I don't really know my impression is
that there aren't good Discovery yeah I
don't think that exists
that's not a feature of well unless it
was known at the time of loading I mean
what caused those things to get loaded
into the kernel because they were
statically linked or they were linked
time not long time ranking they were
build time then at build time we could
in principle produce a manifest
we could dynamically build documentation
at build time well I think it's very
hard like it's like every library that
we statically Link in you'd have to go
into the documentation find all the
symbols that it includes and I I don't
think this is an automatic way to do
this
chat GPT
go read the documentation extract um in
order to make up a bunch of fake
functions half the time or you know yes
yeah yeah right okay and just to be
clear I mean I think it's it's not
necessarily a problem to get the symbol
names it's the types that are hard and
without the types it's not very useful I
see I see it right yeah so in the case
of cause if you typed you know ABC
instead of cos there what would it have
done
it should uh just say dollar fail
although she gives oh that's a real one
it should uh yeah there we go
um it should give a better error message
but yeah right now it just fails why
doesn't it make a failure object that is
a a
um it should no but but it's everything
failure object how the failure object
applied to 5.6 what should it do
Well normally if the other objects
applied to 5.6 it'll look for a key and
failure called 5.6 which is sort of
unfortunate that's unfortunate right I
mean so yeah it'll be possible to make a
good failure object though because
there's this DL error mechanism where
you can get like a string that explains
why it failed right um that's that's it
by the way I thought about that more
that's better in a failure object than a
message because it's unwashed text
coming from the dynamic library
subsystem on your computer which isn't
really I don't know how often we do that
but it's a bit unwashed if you see well
so I think the best way to handle that
would be if there is a meta message that
says there is a message
yes go look in the failure object
Define what it is yeah
okay right all right so let's come back
to
um
I want to come back to this name load
external Library
and its relationship to library load
which seems a bit fraught to me
um right
so they're fundamentally just to explain
what library load is doing again because
it's actually kind of there's a lot of
secret stuff going on inside of Library
load Library load is doing something
very similar to this external Library
load external libraries doing the only
difference is that when you call library
load
um
right you see that I applied to this and
it turns a path
it just what it did is it it loaded this
and it got this this is secretly just a
pointer right and this this got that
same pointer and then what it did is it
put it into a hash table where this path
is the key to the hash table right to
that entry okay so anywhere that I use
this path or or this thing which will
resolve to this path it will secretly
get this same pointer
um
yeah go ahead
well okay one nice feature of doing this
doing it this way actually I mean this
this way is a little bit weird but one
nice feature of it is that when you
write Library function load and you give
it a path and then you know function
name and so on if the library is loaded
it can look in the hash table and it can
uh you know extract it and everything
but if the library is not loaded then in
principle it can it can load the library
which means that you just you wouldn't
ever have to say library load you just
give it these you know calls to library
function loader here foreign function
and only when they're actually used does
it need to library load which is kind of
okay
there's also useful for loading
dependent libraries so if there isn't a
cyclic
circle of dependencies you don't have to
bother with you know Library paths and
things like that you can just do library
load on the dependencies and then load
the actual Library you want with like
Library function but I don't understand
the auto loading mechanism if in foreign
function we supported a string as the
first argument as the extended first
argument and it had the same behavior as
Library load then that would achieve
that same sort of thing yeah
yeah suburbato if we did it that way
or sorry Connor are you going to say
something well I just wasn't sure
because from way the way you're
describing this it sounds like you're
hinting it maybe you you don't agree
with combining Library load with load
external library but
I also don't in your description it
doesn't sound like I'm just a little
confused about what you oh no the web
positions okay
yeah
I I I well I'm not really sure right I
mean I think that the thing is is I
think we can I I think
right the simplest thing is just to to
to only use the path mechanism so just
screw this you know external Library
object
um
right I mean that that doesn't seem
right to me I mean look why not the
following thing why not forget Library
load it's load external Library
then load external Library can take a
uh I mean I'm sorry that that one at the
top the example you had demo lib equals
um that's using a path correct
this is using you can call it a path I
mean it's a it's a thing that you can
feed to find library which will get
resolved to a pan it's not quite a path
because it's it's not even a proper file
name there's no extension to it you see
okay fine fine but but then that if that
was a file name you know with the dot so
extension and so on then it could load
just like Library load does yes and
return an external Library I think the
returning with string seems pointless to
me
and then the reason that you would
return this the reason it Returns the
string right now is that uh is that what
you do is you write you know demo lib
equals this and then when you write this
here this would be a string which is
what this expects and it will just look
up into the hash table and get that
result right but why not allow fireworks
the way it does to I to take either a
string or an external Library object
sure sure yes yeah I mean I I it seems
to me like I I think deprecating Library
load wouldn't really make sense because
it conceptually these things are already
very similar it's just a question of do
we want to have an external Library
object or not and if we do I don't think
we need a whole separate Library loading
function
I mean
one question I mean Library load the
syntax of that string argument is the
same right it can either be a library
name without an extension it could be
with an extension it could be an
absolute file path it and it looks up
relative to Dollar Library path does
load external library look
on dollar Library path it just calls
find library so yes okay so so they're
semantically they're already almost
identical it's just the question of do
we have a new return type
which could make sense but if we do have
a new return type I don't think it
fundamentally changes anything because
we just support that new return type
anywhere that you can currently use that
string argument exactly
right so okay bottom line here is is
anybody
in you know the the deprecating Library
load turning it into load external
library and having the flow as we've
discussed it does that make sense yeah I
I don't know why we would move it well
we can't have one thing called Library
loading another called load external
Library we have no right unless we have
a second usage of Library load like this
Library object thing but but that is
also a little bit like I mean if we had
that second usage but actually you never
need to use it because everything is
compatible with the first usage no one
will ever write right I object to the
idea that there's one thing called
Library load another thing called load
Library
yeah right there can't be yes yeah yeah
I mean deprecating one like Library load
that's a widely used function relatively
speaking I mean it seems unnecessary
churn to deprecate it just to change a
return type
where that new return type doesn't even
offer very many advantages
so to me it makes well what do we mean
by deprecate I mean the fact is we say
you don't have two no I understand that
but continuing to have Library load work
for the foreseeable future but just
having a thing saying this has been
deprecated use light load external
Library instead
seems fine to me I mean this is this is
why I I'm I'm a little you know why I'm
somewhat sympathetic to the argument of
just just only use these strings because
given that we have basically the point
is we have this existing system that's
widely used that we can't get rid of
using the strings
that that isn't that bad it's it's it
would be better if it used something
like this external Library object but
it's not it's not like a disaster
um
have the ability to have other
properties that you could query from it
um well first of all query from it is
not super useful because you could query
them from a string just as well right
well not with not with just properties
sub values sure I don't really know of
any properties because basically there's
no Discovery mechanism for any of these
libraries you can't find out what's
going on easily
yeah I I right I think yeah
um so so one other maybe just to add one
other complexity to this so
right given we're talking about maybe
you know unifying these or how these
interact another question is how Library
function load interacts with this
right because
right I mean obviously these do totally
different things
um I mean this loads a library link
function which has a very specific form
and everything like that and this loads
a general function from a from a dynamic
Library you know and this has all sorts
of things with math link connections and
this doesn't and so on
um but they have the same argument
structure and their names in some ways
kind of mean the same thing
um explain again why they're different
okay
Library function load is for loading
Library link functions Library link
functions have a fixed signature where
you you know you know every Library link
function expects an what is it like an M
argument object in the first argument
and then a you know you know a whatever
in the second argument and whatever in
the third argument then it returns a m
result or something like that right you
have to write the library interface in a
certain what in a special way right so
it's a not very foreign function it's a
it's a uh it's a it's a homely function
at least it's it's it's at the embassy
or something like that yeah yeah it's
nothing like that yeah right but but so
it's it's right and they're also
versions like it takes a math link and
yeah yeah right
um it's very tied to our system it's not
you know you've done something
intentional if you're using that whereas
foreign function is very much you're out
in the wild and I agree that about I
think it makes sense that these are
separate functions because the use cases
the performance characteristics are very
different so firm function probably with
Super C why would you bother with a
library function
well
partly because you have Legacy code
um other than Legacy obviously like you
see but new projects what does Library
function load return
it returns a library function
where the name very similar to foreign
functions
and Library functions right now there's
opaque objects there's no we don't we
don't say anything about inside them all
you can do is you can call them do they
have a summary blob or not
oh they do they do
um
and so
right and actually in fact in compiled
code when you use Library function
declaration which based on some of this
stuff maybe should be foreign function
declaration depending on how we name
everything
so so okay okay right this is this is
another
aspect of it so if I do library function
declaration compiled code
and then and then inside the compiled
code so I have you know function
compile
a function then you've got then you call
that function by default by saying
Library function of you know I don't
know the function name
of blah blah blah right
s the names of the functions in
libraries are always strings yep right
so so now I I like I think this is a
nice design by the way I'm I'm right but
I'm just saying in terms of unifying all
these things right if the distinction
we're making is that Library star
functions are for Library link and
foreign star functions are for these
sort of generalized foreign functions
first of all this should be foreign
function declaration and this should be
foreign function right which is which we
can do that sort of option on the
library function declaration it could be
like foreign function goes you know
foreign interface goes to true or
something or interface goes to foreign
or something no we don't want to do that
look it's called
function as well hold on we're going to
replicate we're going to have many many
of these things like foreign function
declaration we're going to have a whole
zoo of these things like foreign
function declaration would replace
Library function declaration
it also refer to one of our libraries
function declaration could it refer to
one of our libraries or not
you mean libraries compiled with the
compiler or libraries built into the
kernel
I mean okay so as I'm understanding it
one type of library is a standard Dy lib
Dynamic library that came from the wild
and that's what load external Library
deals with
a second and its calling structure is
native that is it's going to put a bunch
of stuff on the stack according to the
type declaration and do it what it does
right as opposed to a library function
that has been created with Library
function load I'm sorry load Library
load and in that case the calling
convention is not native data types
stuck on the stack it's instead our own
structure that's been built using
Library link is that correct
yeah that's mostly correct the the only
thing would be that it's right so I
think maybe let me make a right so we
have you know
oops there we go we have Library loading
mechanisms they're they're three
um there are three similar pads the
first one is the library link path right
then there's the the compiler path and
there's the foreign actually let me put
the compiler one last the foreign
function one second so it's next to the
library link one
foreign functional okay so Library link
you get you call library load then you
call library function load and that
gives you a library function okay and
then you call it
foreign function you call right now you
call load external Library
yep back it and then you call foreign
function to get the form function and
then you use form function to call it
and the compiler mechanism use Library
function load
to basically do both Library load and or
sorry Library function declaration
to do basically the first two steps and
then use Library function
by default to to call it
so okay so the first thing not library
library oh yes
um right okay so so the first thing to
note is that these two mechanisms at the
top these two functions are doing very
similar things the lower two functions
are doing very different things but the
top functions are doing the same thing
basically okay and the reason that the
library link I just understand again the
mechanics
both of these are dealing with a dynamic
library but one of them has they have
different calling conventions for what's
put on the stack to call the external
function is that correct
yes one is a very narrow it has to meet
a certain set of Demands which one the
library the library library function is
like you don't have to do that
right but so in the future very few
people will wrap foreign functions with
the apparatus to make them into Library
functions is that true I think that's
true
because why would you do that you might
as well just go raw to the
um I mean the only reason to to do that
would be this that let's say you're
dealing with an external library and the
external library is Shifting Sands and
you want to have a consistent interface
how would you do that but you you would
do that I mean you do that by just
having a you know a DOT C file that you
compiled that produces something that
foreign function can then load right in
the same way that yeah a common way a
common reason to do that by the way is
if it's a c plus library and the names
all have like weird mangled things
so
they have to be instantiated so all
right okay so so what you're basically
saying is librarylink is kind of old
technology which we are essentially
deprecating in favor of the direct
foreign function mechanism
I don't think we want to say that
library library functions are still
useful even in this new world sometimes
you want to write some of your own glue
code you want to write your own little
wrappers around these C functions and
you just don't want to go direct to
metal from The Wolf of language you know
you could use a okay
convention for library though that's
quite convenient for some types of
arguments to send it you know to use a
link as the as the marshalling mechanism
for removing our in library the library
interface has all sorts of callbacks to
the kernel you know you can do memory
sharing with your arrays and things like
that this is stuff that you can do in
the library link interface that people
will still want all right like if
nothing else there's the the math link
you know if you're doing something weird
with math link and so on it you know you
might want to use Library link and be
you know okay Library function load need
to exist why can it not do the same
thing that foreign function does and
just be Library function and do the load
if it needs to do the love mode
maybe it could okay I think it's nice to
have two different functions actually
but but then why don't we have foreign
function load well we talked about this
right I mean I think we we could have it
but it just means that you you could
still write code like this but it would
look a little ugly it would look like
that or it should be load
what does the um I mean presumably so I
just looked if you do if you look at the
ref Library function documentation page
it has
you know you load it and it looks like
the the symbolic form of Library
function
is identical to what the symbolic form
would be if you were trying to load it
it's like the same as a foreign function
form the first argument is a string
second argument is a function name third
argument is a list of types fourth
argument is the return type so that
would mean every time that form is
evaluated it would have to do a check am
I already loaded am I already loaded am
I already loaded which is presumably why
Library function load is a different
symbol from library function because you
don't have to do a check every time
Library function is evaluated
um only when it's called
so we'd have to change the structure I
think if we wanted to avoid having to do
a check which could get expensive
okay let's go back to the top again for
a second let me understand the compiler
an internal compiler function what is it
in your table there
what is that like is that does that have
the calling convention the stack
structure of a library function or a
foreign function
or neither more like a foreign function
so it's pretty Raw
yeah
yes it's more flexible
not a huge amount of work but probably
not super to allow the compiler to call
library link functions but but we've
never done that
oh my gosh Okay so we've got and why is
the compiler calling it's if it
if it's function to be called it's
called a library function why isn't that
compatible with calling any other
Library function for example one from
library link
right this is sort of the argument for
what I was saying if we're going to make
this distinction between Library star
functions and sort of foreign functions
then these should should all have names
like foreign function declaration
because they're really much more like
the second one
and just to be clear about the naming I
think in the documentation
these Library functions are often
referred to in the context of what are
referred to as Wolfram libraries so
there's kind of this implicit Wolfram on
the front of all those Library star
functions it's Wolfram Library load wolf
from library function load they're
written in the Wolfram Library format
um
okay
what's good that we made that
distinction yes yes it is good
um
okay all right so let's let's
go through this again right I think it's
just it's
it seems like we're going to have a
couple different parallel things we just
should make sure the names are are it's
clear which path you're on and in the
cases where you're on the same path they
should use the same name
um yes no I agree
I mean and
if I could just offer I mean if there's
another reason not to combine foreign
function and Library function which is
if you imagine if you're specifying the
types of the two so for Library function
the type might be integer but if you
just see that in a signature it's like
well in library function that means an
integer passed through the M argument
mechanism it's very specific whereas if
it's meant to be a foreign function that
presumably is something like C in I
agree
yeah yeah I agree
okay so I agree with that can I just
want to say the compiler doesn't need
foreign function because it creates its
own you know builds its own code so it's
not quite so
right it's not calling into this
mechanism but I'm just saying in terms
of the naming right if we have right now
Library functions generally refer to
functions that follow the M argument
mechanism right now the things in the
compiler that we call library functions
you know are not using the M argument
mechanism but you know so if we had this
foreign function concept which
represents generalized native functions
from a dynamic library then that would
be the more relevant name for you know
the compiler to use the application will
be identical why are we calling it
foreign function rather than external
function
it could be
yeah
just because because ffi is a common
brand I I kind of like the term foreign
function because it suggests it's alien
and that things could go very wrong
but in in a sense every library is
external or foreign I mean and
everything and things can go wrong
from libraries
maybe we should have Warframe Library
function and Warframe Library no no no
no no no otherwise we would put that in
front of every function name but what's
the difference between foreign function
and external function as it's used in
external evaluate
well right this is
right I mean one of the things I was
thinking of in the early days of this is
that maybe this could be inside of the
external function mechanism but I think
I I think Todd had some reasons why I
thought that that might not make sense
um
that it might not make sense
Library function foreign function and
external function all of which have
different ways to actually call that
their native functions as I understand
it
do we want to focus on the sort of
location of the library is what we're
defining it as or it's calling
conventions
yeah I think we want to focus on the
calling conventions because those are
the things that we can't you know
they're fairly confusing and we can't
get around having to Define that right
and in that case I think foreign is more
more natural than external yeah I
understand but external function already
does something
external function is calling into a
runtime an external okay so so the
definition is so I understand external
function is calling a runtime
right like it might be calling the
python runtime or it might be calling a
um uh a c runtime and what is the
interface for an external function into
C or do we not have that we don't have
that this would be that if it existed
yeah yeah this would I see so external
function is really calling into a a big
Hefty run time like a wolf and language
runtime or a jvm or something like this
is that correct
right that's that's what it does right
now right so okay we could maybe have
something like this
but yeah but I'm not sure we want that
but I mean so the definition would be to
distinguish these things external
function it's fundamentally calling a
runtime and the runtime is dispatching
to whatever code needs to be dispatched
to and actually executing it
Library function is calling into a
created for the Wolfram Library System
function with the m m argument wrapping
Etc et cetera et cetera foreign function
is going raw to the metal putting you
know types On The Stack
is that correct
yeah
makes sense yeah okay all right so then
then we've got those three levels and we
can Define that we can have a table
somewhere that basically just lists
those three levels which makes sense
this mean word depth we would
deprecating the compiler Library
function declaration and Library
function
and replace the foreign function yeah I
would argue you should just write
deprecate them and just rename them but
identical implementation yeah fine okay
yeah I see okay okay fair enough
okay all right so then then the
remaining issue here is locations and
Library load versus load external
library and also the word external
Library seems wrong it should say
foreign Library if it's going to be that
this some this family
right so
right
I mean I would argue or it should be
foreign Library load really yes it
should be I mean but what was the
argument that Library load couldn't do
or everything
well right actually that that's right
because that's where we started was the
fact that these are different paths but
they intersect at the beginning because
really these two functions are doing
basically the same but they know what
which one it is do they know whether
it's a wolf from library or a foreign
Library it doesn't matter you load them
the same way
I say like you both you just call DL
open
actually there's a little bit of
fundamentally load them the same way the
only thing that you might do differently
is that right now when you call library
load it uses a flag that basically says
load this into the global namespace and
spew it everywhere versus uh uh load
external Library which right now is
doing this mechanism where it sort of
loads it more locally so that you know
you're less likely to have sort of name
collisions but
yeah
so okay
and then one question and I don't think
there's a huge deal per se but one
possible difference between these two
functions is that Library load uh
intentionally calls if the library
defines a function called Wolfram
underscore initialized it will call that
function at the time the library is
loaded hypothetically this load external
Library function might not do that
um I don't think this is a really
distinction worth making a big deal
who's going to Define that function I
mean but by the time you're already in
the jungle and the question of whether
you hang up a you know whatever I I'm
not worried about that yeah okay um
however I do think that the term Library
function
which we are making a distinction
between that and foreign function
it is a little bit you know pulling
things to say
um
if we say okay so if we say library load
both loads foreign functions if it's if
it's a library that contains foreign
functions you then access them with
foreign function but then you just call
it Library when you said Library load
and now
we're distinguishing the library
function
well that's okay I think that's all
right I mean if we called it if we had
just one the one Library load function
and it loads an external library and
that external Library can either contain
foreign functions or Library functions
or maybe both reasonable
right
could you do question mark library
function real quick Christopher I just
want to point out that it does in fact
say explicitly this is for loading from
Wolfram libraries and usage message
yeah okay fine all right okay so
all right so then let's just understand
Library function load what does it do
and is it every function load takes it's
definitely needed this is the thing for
loading the M argument Style
functions but foreign function doesn't
need that explicit loader because why
uh well it
uses a difference
sorry it uses a different one it needs
it just as much as Library function does
except that it's been Consolidated I
mean Library function could be the
Constructor for Library functions but we
just so happen to have done it so it's a
second separate function we could do the
same with form function which is how it
was before
but as we talked about last time it
seems like there's some value in having
it be its own Constructor because then
you can write code
but so why not allow Library function to
also be its own Constructor
I think based on what Connor was saying
it seems like it almost already is
costly is the check yeah it kind of
point is that you have to you have to
basically try to load it every time you
get Library function well why don't you
have to do that for foreign function you
do so before well you you kind of do
right so I think it's it's probably
better and but most of the time you're
not going to call it like this so I
don't think there's too much value and
you know it's it's not it's it's nice
but it's not like super important on
most systems this is like pretty fast
um
you know on on on Mac if you don't do
caching it's quite slow or like it's
like 10 to the minus four right so let
me just say that is not fast
well like in Tennessee
how many CPU time zone CPU instructions
no but like a sub value runs at this
speed a sub value right right you know
so if you if you have any evaluated code
around it this will not be the the
bottleneck right okay but so if we have
it unload then we could avoid this
overhead is that correct
sorry what was that if we had a foreign
function load explicit foreign function
load we could avoid this overhead true
or not true or if you just or if you
just did this right add one equals that
and then you say add one it's because
this this object here it actually
evaluated if I look at the input form
actually this would look a little bit
odd but it uses a data structure thing
inside which serialized in some kind of
broken way but um right so so when you
you know it right so if I if I take this
and I compare it to uh I mean this will
just be immediate right kind of nice
eight and presumably this will be faster
too
why is that so comparatively slow
uh well partly because I haven't yeah
right okay
so so
um
right so there's a value then in
even if
I mean just for people to not get
confused and have slow code
actually hold on just one other thing we
could do and actually I was looking at
how Library function library or how
Library function load does this and I
think it might do something similar so
just as when you call library load it
uses that string of the path and it puts
it in a hash table and it keeps track of
basically the handle for that Library
Library function load I think keeps
track of the function name that you
loaded
and next time you call library function
load it sort of it doesn't actually have
to call DL Sim again it just uses the
function pointer it already had so this
could use a similar mechanism and also
get rid of this the Slowdown
current function foreign function could
right I I do still think though that
writing things like this is probably the
cleaner way to do it if nothing else
because you can do this and then that
way you can sort of lazily
uh or you know you can do
something like this and that way you can
lazily load this once which is kind of
nice yeah
I mean one one question might be are
there cases where you might want to
intentionally construct this symbolic
foreign function representation where
you knowingly don't have that symbol
available and you wouldn't want this to
return an error which is I think what it
would presumably have to return now if
it failed
you mean whatever you want to make a
foreign function that referred to
something that didn't exist and I want
to return unevaluation no no you don't
want to do that
okay hold on I kind of agree I don't
really see good no okay so are you
saying that with this string caching
mechanism I could just disembodiedly run
foreign function of add one
I don't have to set that equal to
anything I could just disembodedly run
that and it would then look up add one
in its string table is that correct it
could I still think it's better code if
you use the symbol and so on and it's
probably more readable too
um but it could work that way this is
also similar to the way compiled code
function works by the way and that uses
uh you know various caches and things
so all right so then provisionally
we imagine that this is the right
mechanism and that Library function load
goes away and that Library function that
you do the same mechanism for Library
function that you do for foreign
function and that you are setting the
SQL to that is that right
and that's just I guess
yeah I'm still I I'm a little nervous
about changing Library load or light
Library function because it's sort of
used in all sorts of bizarre ways oh I
understand that I don't know we don't
have to change it we can leave that
function but we can deprecate it but
support I mean no no because it wouldn't
be a matter of deprecation would be a
matter of making Library function
evaluate which right now it doesn't do
well only evaluating the case where it
is fed where the food it's fed isn't the
food it normally has
yeah I think that food didn't normally
have so so I think I think the way that
Library function works
well actually maybe I should check this
before I say it right because I'm pretty
sure the way it works is that it it
serializes to have an input form that
looks like Library function load but I
think secretly it's a function pointer
so if you actually evaluate
the library function that you get from a
library function load
I'm a little confused I mean the
existing code is going to have Library
function load in it
and yes
uh what am I trying to say
um
okay and that thing has an input form
right and note that this input form
looks identical to the call to library
function load but but this input form I
think is a lie
well yeah I mean I think behind that
means I mean Tom you might know is it
using is it like using like a the
expression hash or something or using
that expression pointer as a key to a
hash table to actually get the
the function pointer I assume it's doing
something
it looks it has a hash table of how I
think it looks up in the library
function it takes the library to get the
functions and then that gives another
hash table it's like a hash table of
hash tables to get the actual yeah right
but basically there's a lot of hashing
going on so that that input forms
there's quite a bit of work to get down
to the actual function pointer right
it's not storing the function pointer in
the library function all right so look
right so actually two things
right do you think he's going to be
quickly mentioned the first thing is
that this I mean of course you can
evaluate this and even in a fresh kernel
this will effectively do identical
things to library function load on the
same arguments it also is a nice feature
that it means that it can it can be
serialized which form function should
also support
um
but yeah
right so this already works it's just
that maybe the error messages are worse
when you don't give it the right
argument let me make a comment about
serialization that
this just like for a bunch of these
large data structure things like audio
we now have this thing that says you
know this is being stored in a local
file do you want to push it to some
globally accessible place
presumably we should do the same thing
here because
the dynamic library or what no no well I
mean okay so the question is you send a
notebook containing one of these things
you have this Dynamic library that you
put on your computer
right you then send the notebook to
somebody else and it won't run
I I see where you're where you're going
but the the properties of dynamic
libraries make this very difficult for
example on Mac Dynamic libraries
um depending on how you build them have
like a built-in path where they have to
be which could be an absolute path on
your computer or if they have dependents
Library dependencies those Library
dependencies are often specified by
default with an absolute path right now
it's going to tell me the libraries are
different for every architecture and
potentially
yes
but I worry about having a notebook I
mean we're trying pretty hard to have it
be the case that you can't just end up
randomly sending somebody a notebook and
have it not work
well so I think just that I mean same
with Library load and so on I mean and
same with import I don't know I see this
a lot like Imports it's like
yeah okay
okay no I agree Imports hopeless
um and you know we have the if you wrap
this your notebook as a packlet then
this stuff exactly exactly yeah yeah
well does it automatically save it out
if you take your notebook and you make
it a packlet it doesn't does it does it
follow the dependency paths
automatically now you have to build the
benefit with the correct files in it and
but then you can distribute it to people
this is an argument for foreign function
load because otherwise you have code
that looks like it's just going to run
it just contains this foreign function
thing but then when you actually try to
do it it's like oh this doesn't work
whereas if you had foreign function load
true
that's that's that's that's all true but
isn't I don't understand important
function performs the foreign function
load operation I I understand that but
I'm saying that in a piece of code
somebody sent you a piece of code
and it contains the thing that says
foreign function you say why on Earth
doesn't this run
I'm totally confused it looks like well
presumably you'll get an error message
that says you'll get the same error
message you get from foreign function
load saying can't find this line all
right okay Fair Point third Point that's
a good argument all right so basically
what what you're describing is Library
function load exists because of certain
details of the way that libraries are
are provisioned
and that you don't need a foreign
function load just because the
provisioning works differently
is that a fast statement I mean you
could have a foreign function load but
it doesn't really need to exist
I I honestly I think that this the the
it's the same it's the same situation
between Library function and you know
and foreign function in this case like I
think
I don't really see a difference between
there being a foreign function mode and
Library function load all right okay
fine but then maybe we should provide
those functions and basically say you
don't have to use them you could use
directly inside Library function
directly inside foreign function but it
will be more efficient if you use
Library function load Etc
is that reasonable I mean it's just
weird because then we have these two
things I mean you have Library function
load of args colon equals foreign
function of args right that would be its
definition I don't know it's just a pure
Alias well and also
I mean the load is already almost a pure
Alias the only difference is that if you
give is it has better error handling all
right so I mean you're advocating that
we basically deprecate Library function
load or or not
no I'm not exactly sure what I'm
advocating okay I'm just saying that I
think yeah so to me a reasonable flow
would be there's Library load and it
loads libraries which are both both
contains foreign functions and Library
functions
then
to provision
the library function of foreign function
are Auto provisioning so to speak
they don't have a separate function that
needs to be run to provision them
correct
okay
that will be that's proposal one I
suggest that we think through that
proposal and if that proposal has a
reason why it's hopeless then then we'll
need that separate load function and
then then the question is do we need
a two functions Library function load
and foreign function load or can we get
away with one on the grounds that for
example I think it's confusing to have
just one okay and I think if we're going
to do that I think it would be something
like
you know
provisional function of something go
ahead I mean the function loading
functions have to be separate I mean
unless you're saying there'd be
different usages of the same function
but that's that's bizarre I think
no fine fine I mean I understand they
have to be separate well I'm concerned
okay okay okay fair enough okay so
you're saying it's either
Library function and foreign function
are Auto provisioning or there's a
library function load and a foreign
function load
I guess so the only thing about that
that that's I mean right here's the the
conflict right at one level I'm I'm I'm
nervous about getting rid of or
deprecating or whatever Library function
load just because and well first of all
it means adding argument checking to
library function which given all the
weird code Library functions used in
maybe could be a problem
well at the same time you know the
alternative or if we want to be
consistent between these two is to have
a foreign function load but I don't
really like the idea of that too much
either because its arguments will be you
know it'll basically just call foreign
function now maybe we can do the same
thing like we can do the same thing that
we do with Library function we're
basically foreign function doesn't check
its arguments at all right it's just a
very dumb wrapper and and foreign
function load does check its arguments
and that's the difference I just think
that it's not a super useful thing but
it maybe we should do that just to be
consistent
that would be my suggestion let's let's
move on here yeah go ahead okay keep
keep foreign function load I
I it seems to me that we should just say
we never needed Library function load in
the first place so let's just make
Library function important function both
to the with Stephen
let's let's investigate these two
possibilities we don't know which one is
going to work okay there may be some
gotchas that we're not thinking of right
now
I think we understand okay so this
segment I think we understand so maybe
we should just keep going well yeah and
I'm gonna have to go in a few minutes
but um right okay so maybe um all right
so the next thing that I did this is
also a
kind of somewhat large change I'll
actually killed my kernel at some point
um
so right so I I based on our discussion
last time I added uh I added some typed
pointers so last time I started arguing
why you know in the current system there
was only opaque pointers but now I have
I have some typed pointers
um and the reasoning for this create
buffer is that is that
you're we're gonna kind of get to that
right so there's a whole zoo of
functions which are sort of the the
functions for creating inputs for you
know functions for creating inputs and
interpreting outputs from C you know
from foreign functions right foreign
maybe yeah so so let me show maybe the
zoo of
well okay so so there's a whole zoo of
these functions
um which I don't think we're gonna have
time to go over all of them right now
um I noticed a comment on the live
stream about resource function failing
and giving a failure object that then
gets confused when it is fed
um uh sub-value looking arguments let's
bring that up in the LCC meeting okay
separate issue
best case
yes it's that case
yeah actually that's not too bad because
it said if that return a failure object
would be more broken but yeah
um right okay let's bring this up now
okay this is a separate discussion okay
right okay right so so basically
uh the point is there's a whole bunch of
these functions right now I've been
using the term buffer that's kind of a
weird term
um to basically mean pointer to some
memory
um
right there's a whole bunch of these
these functions the main reason why I
added this raw pointer type was because
all these functions that take a buffer
pretty much all of them that take a
buffer have to be told what is the type
of the things
and sometimes if it's an array they also
you know how long the array is but it's
not always an array
um so right so the idea is if you have
this raw pointer type then you know they
don't have to ask you about the type
every time and and most of the time you
do know the type and if you don't know
the type then I have it so that you know
if you have a you can say raw pointer of
another raw pointer
yeah I see so this will cost well he
does the it casts it by just telling it
that the type is different right which
means it has a different stripe
right yes
but this is mostly useful if this thing
is like an opaque raw pointer which sort
of like a void star
um so you know if you have an opaque one
you can tell actually it's specifically
an array of integers and now you can go
in I mean I can imagine weird cases in
which you want to read floats as um uh
as they're a bit pattern and so on sure
you could do that with this
um
but um
right so so I guess the um
right okay and and one other thing about
the pointers although this is sort of a
question here but I think I know what it
should do so one question is how much so
our type checking should it do between
pointers so my sort of argument was if a
function expects an opaque raw pointer
you can give it any kind of pointer
and if it expects to pointer with a
specific type you have to give it a
pointer of that type maybe also if it
expects a specific type you should be
able to give it an opaque raw pointer
but just no other raw pointer of a
different type if that makes sense yeah
I think that's right I mean because an
opaque raw pointer as its memory will be
sliced up by the by the caller
right it says there may be an opaque
pointer has the type of all you know all
pointers yeah it's a union type of
pointer yeah okay so so if you're
expecting a pointer to an integer you
can be given an opaque raw pointer and
you'll accept it you don't have to
explicitly tell it but then you do the
slicing into integer strides
right right okay fine uh I think that
that makes sense
um
right now okay so let's talk about the
word buffer
and right so actually the first thing I
should say about the word buffer okay
because this is the is there's a bit of
a relation so okay
um
right there's a function there's
functions two raw pointer and from raw
pointer in the compiler which are
functions I'm seeing the function unload
external Library what is that why isn't
it just called unload Library
what we already have on the library this
is just to go and load external Library
right which we're now saying should be I
think we're now saying that or actually
I guess we we didn't totally resolve it
but at least one of right you're going
to load libraries always with Library
load there is no Library X load extra
library and then uh which means there's
a library unload as well
yeah which there already is
okay all right okay but that with that
distinction potentially be a reason to
not have foreign function banned Library
function Auto load the library because
it kind of if you imagine you have an
explicit unload Library call but then
you happen to have a subsequent called a
library function that just silently
reloads the library when you didn't want
that to happen
well also you have no way to even have a
pointer to the library to unload it
if it was implicitly Auto provisioned
well no you give it a pass because
there's a paths just do this why do you
unload libraries what's the point of
unloading libraries
I see little points no on Windows you
you need to do it on Windows like you
might need to replace the library if
it's um if it's loaded you can't windows
won't let you overwrite a file that's
that's the library so what do you mean
by replace it you mean so suppose
suppose you're developing a library link
Library you compile one version of it
load it test it it's wrong you make a
fix and you don't want to have to quit
your internal section you have to unload
and then reload on Windows right okay I
didn't know Windows had this problem
but we could we could easily have it be
the case that if you do a library load
on top of an existing library that it
behind the scenes unloads the thing
before loading it why wouldn't we do
that no no no that that's not the time
you do it it's when you rerun your
compiler outside of you know your Visual
Studio outside of Oh you mean you mean
you call unload before you overwrite the
dynamic Library file exactly does it
work because it refuses to overwrite the
dynamic Library
yes it refuses oh
if it's been loaded I see yeah
yeah okay right next yeah okay yeah okay
so so all right anything I I I have to
go in just a moment but I guess the
basic thing and this is maybe we should
spend you know next time talking about
is is the design of all these functions
there is a bit of a relation to True raw
pointer from not pointer like there
there's you know two of these functions
that are kind of analogous to these
um but they're also a bunch of functions
that don't have much of a compiler
analog although the analog these
functions probably could also be
imported into the compiler because
basically the way you do these
operations the compiler is usually with
this General function called create type
instance which does all sorts of stuff
but like you might do something like you
know
write this and this is kind of like
um list to buffer of you know one two
three
um
I think here I have to specify that the
the you know I think we're running out
of time you're going too quickly for me
to understand
um okay fine well basically there's
there's all these functions they need
designs but also the uh uh there's some
relation to a couple things in the
compiler where either the compiler
should sort of import some of these
symbols in order to be consistent
um but also there's a couple of existing
symbols in the compiler that maybe this
should inherit from but okay question do
we have a big queue of libraries that
are waiting to be linked
just so we make sure that these
mechanisms actually cover the things
that actually happen like like that ref
prop library for example is that one
that is plausibly going to fit into
these mechanisms I I still haven't
looked at that Library I think there was
a lot a link to our library using the
compiler and and and this covers kind of
all the same stuff I'd also say that
this covers
almost every behavior of dynamic
libraries I think maybe the actually in
fact I think it covers every single
behavior
um the only thing I think it might not
really covers globals
um but it probably could
um
okay okay
um all right you need to go we should
wrap this up we should set another 16.
it's going to be presumably you need I
it looks like there might even be time
tomorrow but but um are we going to need
another hour and a half we probably are
on these things yeah
okay all right I look forward to it and
um let's wrap up for now thanks to folks
on the live stream see you all soon hey
bye